[Aplausos]
[Música]
hoy vamos a hablar de corea del sur o
como diría kim jong-un corea la mala tal
vez recordéis a este país porque es el
lugar donde se ha fabricado vuestro
teléfono móvil
vuestra televisión o vuestro coche o
simplemente porque es donde se compuso
esta polémica canción o punk andamos
todos
efectivamente corea del sur es toda una
potencia y no solo a nivel cultural sino
también económico seguramente todos
vosotros tengáis en vuestra casa algún
producto de marca hyundai samsung o lg
las empresas surcoreanas están on fire y
esto debería sorprendernos si tenemos en
cuenta que en 1960 corea del sur era uno
de los países más pobres del mundo y no
hablamos de pobreza relativa por
aquellos años hasta gabón zimbabue
estaban más desarrollados sin embargo en
sólo una generación los surcoreanos han
pasado de morirse de hambre a ser una de
las sociedades más prósperas del planeta
así que la pregunta es que han hecho en
corea del sur para ser tan ricos
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque ya sé lo
que estáis pensando otro vídeo más de
visual política en el que os vamos a
contar cómo un país se hizo
multimillonario gracias al capitalismo y
el libre mercado verdad pues siento
defraudaros porque el caso de corea del
sur tiene unas peculiaridades muy
especiales por supuesto que comparados
con su vecino del norte los surcoreanos
viven en un paraíso de libertades pero
lo cierto es que su modelo económico
tiene una peculiaridad que lo hace
distinto de cualquier otro
así que la pregunta es cuáles son las
razones que explican el progreso de
corea del sur y lo que es más importante
por qué es tan polémico el can am style
estas dos preguntas están relacionadas y
hoy las vamos a responder en este vídeo
[Música]
de arriba hacia abajo como ya sabéis en
1953 la península coreana se divide en
dos mitades tras una guerra que se lleva
por delante a más de dos millones de
personas y en este momento es cuando si
se podía decir que corea del sur era
corea la mala
[Música]
en la parte norte era donde estaban
todas las fábricas del país el sur era
agrícola y completamente subdesarrollado
los colegios no tenían pupitres y el
único alimento que les llegaba a muchos
niños era la leche en polvo que llegaba
de eeuu y de europa
por eso en 1960 tras varias protestas
ciudadanas en general parks jongil da un
golpe de estado y se hace con el poder
así comienza la primera de varias
dictaduras militares surcoreanas durante
los siguientes 27 años corea del sur
tuvo tres dictadores distintos y todos
ellos llegaron al poder de manera
violenta y derrocando al anterior jefe
de estado con un levantamiento militar
[Música]
sin embargo pese a la inestabilidad
política es en estos años cuando se
ponen las bases del modelo económico
surcoreano pero esperad un momento
porque este modelo no es tan liberal
como podría aparecer en un sistema del
libre mercado la economía se regula de
abajo hacia arriba es decir que son las
empresas privadas las que deciden que
cuándo y cómo vender después llega el
estado y regula la actividad económica
con leyes y reglamentos pues bien el
caso de park chung hee fue todo lo
contrario la economía se reguló de
arriba hacia abajo
[Música]
su política consistió en reunirse en una
habitación con las familias más
poderosas del país las cuales
controlaban prácticamente toda la
poquita industria que había en corea del
sur entre estas familias ya estaban los
dueños de lg o de samsung por ejemplo
así que park chung y se sentó con todos
estos empresarios y les dijo a partir de
ahora os voy a dar todo lo que
necesitéis para crecer
que un año no podéis pagar impuestos no
pasa nada os los perdonamos que
necesitáis algún tipo de subvenciones
pues no os preocupéis que el gobierno os
las dará si en algún momento tenéis que
pedir prestado a algún banco o alguna
entidad extranjera el estado surcoreano
os respalda es más si por lo que sea no
podéis devolverlo
el gobierno también os ayudará a saldar
vuestras cuentas
[Música]
si somos débiles nuestro país estará en
peligro para que un país no caiga debe
cultivar sus propias fortalezas sin
embargo a diferencia de otros países
como francia corea del sur no puso
ninguna barrera contra el comercio
exterior es más desde el primer momento
corea del sur garantizó la estabilidad
jurídica y los impuestos bajos para
todas las empresas vinieran de donde
vinieran pero no sólo eso park chung y
también dio toda clase de incentivos
fiscales para que tanto las empresas
como los particulares pudieran invertir
y ahorrar dinero
dicho de otra forma estos grupos
empresariales tan famosos como hyundai o
lotes tenían que competir en un mercado
abierto con los gigantes de japón o eeuu
pero a la vez el gobierno les ayudaba y
les marcaba el camino y como corea del
sur no es un lugar con muchos recursos
naturales pero sí tiene mucha población
estas niñas bonitas del gobierno se
centraron en aquellos sectores que solo
necesitan mucha mano de obra es decir
las manufacturas y así es como nació
[Música]
el país de los 'tablets' imaginad la
vida de uno de los cien mil trabajadores
que trabajan para samsung en corea del
sur se levanta por la mañana en un
edificio construido por 20 que es la
constructora del grupo samsung
[Música]
mientras desayuna mira el último vídeo
del canal de visual política en inglés
porque como sabéis eso es lo que hace la
gente inteligente pero lo hace desde su
teléfono móvil samsung después se baja a
la calle y se monta en su coche de marca
renault barra samsung porque como sabéis
en corea del sur- los coches de marca
renault están fabricados por samsung ya
que no adivina es con qué empresa tiene
contratado el seguro de automóvil
[Música]
efectivamente con la aseguradora del
grupo samsung después de trabajar en
efectivamente en esa empresa a este
señor le apetece tomarse unas cervezas
con sus compañeros de oficina y adonde
creéis que se va a la cantina de
efectivamente lo habéis adivinado
[Música]
pero llega el fin de semana ya este
señor surcoreano le apetece pasar unos
días con su mujer y con sus hijos en un
parque de atracciones aquel parque de
atracciones creéis que va pues por
sorprendente que parezca samsung también
tiene un parque de atracciones
en otras palabras samsung lo es todo
para sus trabajadores hablamos del árbol
más importante de todo corea del sur
pero que es un chaib all los árboles son
estos grandes conglomerados
empresariales auspiciados por el estado
muchos de ellos como por ejemplo de aebu
que ya ha desaparecido fueron impulsados
por la propia administración pública
surcoreana
otros como el grupo hyundai nacieron en
los años 40 todos ellos eran empresas
familiares inicialmente pero han
terminado teniendo cientos de
accionistas y se dedican a fabricar todo
tipo de cosas para que os hagáis una
idea
lg famosa por sus televisiones y sus
teléfonos móviles es también la
responsable en corea del sur de
distribuir la cocacola
en total hay unos 100 árboles en corea
del sur y son el principal activo de la
economía de este país y como os decía el
gobierno les pone una alfombra roja pero
tampoco les da un cheque en blanco es
más cuando un árbol tan grande como
daewoo tuvo que caer nadie fue a
rescatarlo y esto sirve como incentivo
para crear una de las culturas
corporativas más innovadoras que existen
donde todo se aprovecha
[Música]
por ejemplo en 2008 la japonesa sony
quiso desarrollar los primeros
televisores led del mercado pero la
tecnología todavía no estaba del todo
madura y los televisores eran demasiado
caros e incluso como para venderlos en
el mercado de lujo así que que hicieron
pues guardaron el proyecto en un cajón
para la próxima vez la surcoreana lg
también tenía esta tecnología y también
se dieron cuenta de que todavía no la
podían utilizar para fabricar
televisores así que que creéis que
hicieron puedes utilizarla para hacer
teléfonos móviles que tienen la pantalla
más pequeña es decir que no sólo
aprovecharon su propia tecnología sino
que además con el paso del tiempo la
perfeccionaron hasta ser capaces de ser
los primeros en sacar televisores led a
un precio razonable
pero esperad un momento porque hay otra
pieza imprescindible para explicar esta
cultura tan innovadora
la educación surcoreana todos lo sabemos
los niños surcoreanos siempre están en
los puestos más altos del informe pisa--
el país entero se paraliza cuando llegan
las pruebas de acceso a las
universidades y las escuelas de corea
del sur no reparan el más mínimo gasto
para garantizar la formación de sus
chicos y sus chicas por supuesto la otra
cara de la moneda es que corea del sur
es el país con la tasa de suicidios
infantiles más alta del mundo bueno en
realidad el país entero tiene un
problema en este aspecto de hecho corea
del sur es el segundo país con la mayor
tasa de suicidios per cápita
[Música]
lo cierto es que desde el principio el
gobierno entendió que para que estos
chavales pudieran desarrollarse
necesitaban una mano de obra muy
cualificada
así que diseña un sistema educativo a la
medida de sus empresas los niños
surcoreanos son calculadoras humanas
capaces de memorizar cualquier cosa en
muy poquito tiempo y su respeto por la
autoridad es prácticamente religioso y
precisamente por eso ninguno de ellos se
lanza a montar una empresa el sueño de
todo surcoreano es terminar trabajando
para uno de estos chavales como si fuera
un funcionario si tiene suerte y trabaja
duro es probable que le hagan directivo
y termine viviendo en ese paraíso en la
tierra ese barrio de lujo situado en
seúl y conocido con el nombre de gangnam
suena de algo
con gastar
qué significa el gángster
joya una chica humana y cálida durante
el día con clase que sabe disfrutar de
la libertad de una taza de café pero que
cuando llega la noche su corazón se
calienta porque es una chica con dos
caras y chica sexy yo tengo el estilo de
ghana este es un trozo de esa letra que
todos hemos cantado borrachos en algún
momento de nuestra vida y una de las
razones por las que su cantante side ha
tenido que pagar alguna que otra multa
por escribir canciones con contenido
inapropiado
[Música]
en una sociedad obsesionada con la
jerarquía y el respeto a la autoridad la
estética del site es algo así como los
movimientos de cadera de elvis en los
años 50 pero lo cierto es que esta
economía tan autoritaria y tan
dependiente de unas pocas grandes
empresas no parece la mejor receta para
la estabilidad económica de un país de
hecho es verdad que corea del sur es
líder en la manufactura tecnológica pero
en otros sectores como por ejemplo los
servicios profesionales está muy por
detrás y como el crecimiento de los
chabolas ha estado influido por las
decisiones del gobierno durante años los
nuevos emprendedores lo han tenido
particularmente difícil
[Música]
no podían acceder a los mismos
beneficios y encima sufrían la
competencia desleal de los grandes
conglomerados no sólo eso estas
estructuras jerárquicas tan del gusto de
los surcoreanos no son tan eficientes
como podría aparecer la mayoría de estos
árboles se han convertido en gigantes
burocráticos cada vez más caros de
mantener para que os hagáis una idea
samsung lidera las ventas de teléfonos
móviles en todo el mundo sin embargo
apenas son capaces de sacar beneficios
con esta línea de negocio y esto puede
ser un problema en el medio y largo
plazo
sin embargo las cosas están empezando a
cambiar muchos surcoreanos que se han
educado en europa o en eeuu están
regresando a su país con ideas
totalmente nuevas mucho más
emprendedoras más críticas y más
creativas y están montando sus primeras
empresas de servicios y las primeras
startups surcoreanas pero ojo porque
todavía queda mucho camino por recorrer
pero en cualquier caso nos guste o no
hay que reconocer que este modelo de
crecimiento surcoreano que funciona de
arriba hacia abajo ha funcionado
aunque todavía quedan algunas preguntas
pendientes qué pasaría si por ejemplo un
día
samsung quebrará a dónde se iría el país
entero no sólo eso como os podéis
imaginar este matrimonio entre grandes
empresas y políticos genera muchísima
corrupción pero de eso vamos a hablar en
un próximo vídeo mientras tanto parece
que muchas empresas chinas quieren
seguir el mismo camino que han marcado
las surcoreanas podrán conquistar el
mundo estos gigantes asiáticos hacer
clic en este vídeo para saberlo
y ahora la pregunta es creéis que este
modelo de desarrollo tan dirigista
podría funcionar en otros países qué
opináis de este sistema me podéis dejar
vuestras respuestas en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]